President Trump continues his working
vacation at his Golf Club in New Jersey
amid concerns of increased racial
tension in Washington and
Charlottesville this weekend
add to that claims by his former adviser
and reality TV co-star Omarosa Manigault
Newman that she heard mr. Trump use
racial insults Errol Barnett is
traveling with the president in New
Jersey
Errol good morning good morning yes
despite leading president Trump's
outreach efforts to African Americans
during her time as one of his top paid
advisors in the West Wing
Omarosa is now poised to profit from her
upcoming book in which she claims to
have witnessed the president's racial
insensitivity it is a dramatic twist as
to former reality TV stars clashed over
the most divisive issue in the country
right now racism on the one-year
anniversary of the deadly majolica
protests you have heard this tape you
heard the President of the United States
President of the United States use not
only the n-word other horrible things
speaking on National Public Radio about
her book titled unhinged and inside his
account of the Trump White House
Manigault Newman claims to have heard
offensive recordings of President Trump
from his time on the reality TV show The
Apprentice
despite her book out Tuesday showing she
only heard accounts of such a tape in
which Trump used the n-word quote
multiple times throughout the show's
taping during off-camera outtakes in
excerpts obtained by The Washington Post
Manigault Newman writes that President
Trump is a quote racist misogynist and a
bigot the president made a commitment he
made a promise it is a far cry from her
time as the president's top cheerleader
on African American issue the White
House resisted efforts to say silent on
Friday with press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders shooting back quote
this book is riddled with lies and false
accusations now President Trump himself
has not yet directly responded to
Manigault Newman's claims instead he had
dinner
Apple CEO Tim Cook as he spends leisure
time here in New Jersey it is unclear
though how long that will last
as Omarosa is set to share what she
knows on television tomorrow Tony all
right Errol Barnett traveling with the
president for us looks like rain in New
Jersey maybe no golf today we might see
some better activity I know I do not
make this up I mean it's as if someone
wrote this for a Hollywood script would
believe it if they did they'd be tossed
out if a Hollywood script right not
these days strains credulity you'd think
he said she said but when their tapes
now there may be something but it's also
she said she said she contradicts
herself in her own book apparently we
need the tapes